Thank you.
Okay.
We'll open up the subcommittee work session on Senate bill 235.
And just to review.
Representative Terry's not here.
Representative Post is here.
And let's see, uh, Sally Hunt here.
Calabro is here.
And Vincent not here.
And Gibbs is here.
And Burroughs is here.
Okay.
Two, three.
All right.
And okay, so Representative Patusek is sitting in for Terry.
No, that makes us even.
we're all set okay um so uh as my understanding is that everybody would much rather have this problem solved at the insurance department level and so we're we're very confident that that discussion is going on and it will occur.
And so if we retain this bill, we'll get an update come this fall.
And hopefully the issues have been resolved.
So I will make a motion to retain.
Second.
Two seconds.
So you don't have to worry.
No.
This is exact.
Oh, sorry.
It sorry it's right but you're practicing okay okay okay so the motion is to retain is the question clear all those in favor please say aye all.
All those opposed, so move unanimously.
And this is Senate Bill 235-6-0.
Okay.
That's it.
Thank you.
Okay.
Okay, so.
Who are you missing?
What, I see.
Go through Terry.
Who is in my seat next to.
Yeah, yeah.
to the person we're missing now is oh that's jack That's Jack.
Yeah.
We were told Petrie was.
Jack was Guthrie.
Oh, it's Guthrie.
Who's Guthrie?
I don't know.
We're in permaculary.
Okay, yeah.
Okay.
We're just looking for Guthrie.
Petrie, right?
Petrie who did you say was sitting in for you're singing for macular but didn't you give us another name for uh oh we misunderstood joe guthrie uh no that's john uh oh i'm sorry yeah never mind all right okay okay so it doesn't matter we got a pairing at the moment okay well no guthrie is he moment we're missing a damn because vincent's not here right and we're missing guthrie.
We just lost the door.
Make it even.
And so we have parity.
At this moment, we have parity.
Is Vincent coming?
We can only assume he's supposed to be here.
So at this moment, this is like the old days.
We would just call it pairing.
Senate used to do this all the time.
Okay.
I'm going to work from the exec list.
first up is uh senate bill 21 relative to the due date and delivery of monthly reports and fees to the liquor commission who would like to make the motion don't all speak at once okay okay Okay.
Okay.
So, Representative Burroughs, seconded by Representative Patusek, Moosa ought to pass.
And Patusek.
Representative Burroughs, do you want to speak to your motion?
Thank you.
and Ed Patusek.
Representative Burroughs, do you want to speak to your motion?
I see this somewhat of a housekeeping bill.
It's relative to the due date and delivery of monthly reports and fees to the Liquor Commission, and I don't think it was terribly controversial.
We passed it in subcommittee 5-0.
Okay.
Any discussion on Senate Bill 21?
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll.
Representative Ammon?
Aye.
Representative Osborne?
Yes.
Representative Patusick?
Representative, do I include myself at this point?
Yes, you do.
Yes.
For Representative.
Say Posen and say yes.
Yeah.
And the Representative Guthrie is not here right now uh representative cole yes representative porcelli yes representative taxton yes representative walsh yes representative burrows yes Representative Herbert.
Yes.
Representative Lane.
burrows yes representative herbert representative lane yes representative jack yes representative business it is not here representative collaborative yes representative filialt yes representative gibbs yes representative spear yes representative sullivan 16 to 0 and representative hunt yes and representative hunt i apologize 17 to 0.
okay so the vote was uh 17 17 to 0.
Okay, so the vote was 17 to 0.
17 to 0.
All those in favor of placing on the consent calendar, say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed?
So move unanimously.
Okay.
So this is 7 to 0.
And then...
Okay.
Yep, that's good.
All right.
Okay.
Next up Senate bill 31 relative to technical changes to the laws administered by the insurance department.
Anybody want to make a motion on this one?
Okay.
Representative Calabro, seconded by Representative Patusek, moves to pass on set of Bill 31.
You want to speak your motion?
There you go.
Housekeeping.
There you go housekeeping.
I'm sorry.
It's a cleanup housekeeping bill that I understood regarding the third party administration bond prepayment of judgments should be required I think you were changing the words to that and the typo was corrected I understand oh it was and then is this amended Okay, sorry.
So we'll be sure to this one.
Right.
And we need the amendment number.
Anybody have the amendment number in front of them?
Yep.
420 J5.
No, that wouldn't be it.
No, the typo was correct.
I'm sorry.
This is Senate Bill 31.
Yeah, no, I have.
That's all I have in my notes.
You had no amendment on this one.
I think they had already typo, corrected the typo then when we got it.
Okay.
There's no amendment on this one.
All right.
Okay.
So the pending motion is out to pass.
Any discussion on the motion?
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll representative amman yes representative osborne representative patusick yes representative guthrie is not here excuse me uh representative post yes representative cole yes representative presley yes representative faxton yes representative walsh representative walsh it's okay that's eight um representative burrows yes representative herbert yes representative lane yes representative jack yes representative vincent is not here uh representative calabro yes representative filialt yes representative gibbs yes representative spear yes representative sullivan yes representative Gibbs yes representative Spear yes representative Sullivan representative Hunt yes that's 18 okay 18 the actions that other one must been 18.
okay the motion passes a vote of 18 is it all those in favor placing Senate bill 31 on the consent calendar please say aye aye those opposed so move dynamically okay senate bill 64 establishing a study committee on resident owned manufactured housing park disputes and oversight of resident-owned manufactured housing parks and uh i think we we're going to retain this.
Okay.
Representative Patusek, seconded by Representative Burroughs, moves to retain Senate Bill 64.
Is there any discussion on the motion to retain?
Okay.
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll when she's ready.
And we're still on.
So that is Representative Ammon?
Yes.
Representative Osborne?
Representative Patusick?
Yes.
Representative Guthrie is not here.
Representative Post is yes.
Representative Cole.
Yes.
Representative Percelli.
Representative Thaxton.
Yes.
Representative Walsh.
Representative Burroughs.
Yes.
Representative Herbert.
Representative Lane.
Yes.
Representative Jack.
Representative Vincent is not here.
Representative Calabro.
Yes.
Representative Filiot.
Representative Gibbs.
Yes.
Thank you.
jack yes representative vincent is not here representative collaboro yes representative filialt yes representative gibbs yes representative merrill excuse me representative spear yes representative sullivan yes okay uh senate bill 64 uh retain uh 18 to zip all those in favor placing on the consent calendar please say aye oh that's right we don't do that okay never mind okay I liked in the old days when I get just to term and most.
Okay.
Senate Bill 67.
Right.
There's no amendment for 67, right?
Yeah.
No amendment, right?
Okay.
I will move to pass on Senate Bill 67, seconded by Representative Patusek.
And this is one of those classic inside baseball issues of weights and measures.
It's always interesting.
We had one last year and this year.
Any other discussion?
Anybody have anything else they want to comment?
Seeing none, okay, the clerk will call the roll on Senate Bill 67 to pass.
Representative Ammon?
Yes.
Representative Osborne?
Representative Patusick?
Yes.
Representative Guthrie is not here.
Representative Post?
Yes.
Representative Cole?
Representative Perselle?
Yes.
Representative Thaxton.
Representative Walsh.
Yes.
Representative Burroughs.
Representative Herbert.
Yes.
Representative Lane.
Representative Jack.
Yes.
Representative Calabro.
Representative Vincent is not here.
Representative Filiyalt.
Yes.
Representative Gibbs.
Representative Spear.
Yes.
Representative Vincent is not here.
Representative Filiot.
Yes.
Representative Gibbs.
Representative Speer.
Yes.
Representative Sullivan.
Representative Hunt.
Yes.
18-23.
Okay.
Move to place Senate Bill 67 on the consent calendar.
All those in favor, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed?
Motion passes 18 to zip.
Okay.
Senate Bill 82 relative to prompt payments for managed care.
We're retaining this.
So I'll make the motion uh to retain um this is uh obviously uh would generate a lot of interest and we very much are looking forward to see whether the insurance department has refereed this thing properly come come september um excuse me mr chair yeah um thank you uh i i didn't realize who testified against this bill until i read the minutes from the senate and i had to recuse myself from this vote.
Recuse yourself?
I just wanted to go on record.
My former law firm is representing people.
Ah, so you want to take Rule 16.
Okay.
Thank you.
So, yeah, and further reference, all you do is technically you should just walk out of the room.
Okay.
But it's nice to know we will you know give give you a waiver because of a conflict of interest in rule 16.
okay the clerk will call the role on retaining senate bill uh putusik representative amin yes representative osborne representative patusik yes representative guthrie Thank you.
Representative Ammon.
Yes.
Representative Osborne.
Representative Patusick.
Yes.
Representative Guthrie is not here.
Representative Post.
Yes.
Representative Cole.
Representative Porcelli.
Yes.
Representative Thaxton.
Representative Walsh.
Yes.
Representative Burroughs.
Representative Herbert.
Yes.
Representative Lane is not voting.
Representative Jack.
Yes.
Representative Vincent is not here.
Representative Calabro.
Yes.
Representative Filiot.
Representative Gibbs.
Yes.
Representative Speer.
Representative Philly Ault.
Yes.
Representative Gibbs.
Representative Speer.
Yes.
Representative Sullivan.
Representative Hunt.
Yes.
So that's 17 to 0.
Okay.
And that is 17 to 0.
Retain.
No.
No, this one's.
Oh, 18.
I'm going to jump my gun here.
Okay.
Yeah, so that bill is retained.
Vote 17 is it.
Okay.
Next up, Senate Bill 98, relative delinquent payments of accounts by an on-Premise and Off-Premise Licensee.
You want to do this, John?
Okay.
Representative Patusek, seconded by Representative Burroughs, moves to pass on Senate Bill 98.
And Representative Patusek is recognized to speak to his motion.
This bill increases the total amount of delaying payments by an dollar amount that need necessary to report yes raises the dollar amount from $100 250 and that's basically the change that's it correct okay fiscal impact any discussion on the motion of uh to pass on senate bill 98 seeing none the clerk will call the roll representative bam Ammon.
Yes.
Representative Osborne.
Representative Patusick.
Yes.
Representative, I'm sorry, Guthrie is not here.
Representative Post is yes.
Representative Cole.
Yes.
Representative Percelli.
Representative Thaxton.
Yes.
Representative Walsh.
Representative Burroughs.
Yes.
Representative Herbert.
Representative Lane.
Yes.
Representative Jack.
Representative Vincent is not here.
Representative Calabro.
Yes.
Representative Filiot.
Representative Gibbs?
Yes.
Representative Speer?
Representative Sullivan?
Yes.
Representative Hunt?
18 to 0.
Okay.
Vote pass 18 to zip.
And all those in favor of placing it on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed?
so move dynamically.
Okay.
Senate Bill 99 has an amendment.
So we don't have the files here.
Let me see.
I have it.
We are doing what number?
here.
Let me see.
I have it in here.
We are doing what number?
Senate Bill 99.
99.
So usually we have the file.
Well, I do not have a file unless carried that in here.
Usually it's in the...
Okay.
So I will move with seconded by Representative Beer.
And it's going to be Amendment No.
1456.
And do we put the.
So, yeah, usually.
It's.
Thank you.
Thank you for the other one for the OTPAS as amended.
So do this one first.
Good.
Yep.
Okay.
Everybody got it?
So what we did is in the testimony, there was some conversation that obviously post-COVID, we all learned the benefits of virtual audits.
We're using virtual.
and so in this case the bill to change rather than just getting rid of the language about the auto we were just going to say at least at least one on site or virtual audit so that that they do have a face-to-face meeting in terms of the audit any anybody have any questions okay so uh so the motion is yeah spirit okay the clerk will call the roll on ought to pass on the amendment number 1456.
representative amin yes representative osborne representative Yes.
Representative Terry.
Yes.
Representative Osborne.
Representative Patusick.
Yes.
Representative Terry.
Excuse me.
He's not here today.
Representative Post is here.
Yes.
Representative Cole.
Representative Percelli.
Yes.
Representative Thaxton.
Representative Walsh.
Yes.
Representative Burroughs.
Representative Herbert.
Yes.
Representative Lane.
Representative Walsh.
Yes.
Representative Thoros.
Representative Herbert.
Yes.
Representative Lane.
Representative Jack.
Yes.
Representative Vincent is not here.
Representative Calabro.
Yes.
Representative Philly Ault.
Representative Gibbs.
Yes.
Representative Spear.
Representative Sullivan.
Yes.
Representative Hunt.
That is 18 to zip.
Okay.
All right.
The motion now is ought to pass as amended on Senate Bill 99.
And anybody want to make the motion?
So I'll make it with Representative Spears my second.
Okay.
Senate Bill 99 as amended.
Any discussion on the motion?
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll when she's ready.
Okay.
That is Representative Am yes representative osborne representative patusick yes representative uh guthrie is not here representative post yes representative cole yes representative porcelli yes representative faxton Yes.
Representative Walsh.
Yes.
Representative Burroughs.
Representative Herbert.
Yes.
Representative Porcelli yes representative faxton representative Walsh yes representative Burroughs yes representative Herbert yes representative Lane yes representative Mac Jack yes representative incident is not here but representative Calabro yes representative Filio yes representative Gibbs Representative Gibbs?
Representative Speer?
Yes.
Representative Sullivan?
Representative Hunt?
Yes.
Okay.
The vote is 18 to zip.
All those in favor of placing on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed?
So moved.
Okay.
So who would like to make the inexpedient motion for 102?
Well, we got one for you.
I have Representative Philips.
Move ITL on SB 102.
Just a second.
Sure.
Representative Felix, seconded by Representative Patusek, moves out to ITL, Senate Bill 102.
Now you are recognized to speak to your motion.
There may be some evidence that the heating market may not be impacted by the Jones Act.
Beyond that, this is a federal issue and it's probably better addressed by our federal delegation.
Okay.
Any other discussion on the motion of inexperience to legislate?
I'm lost here.
Sorry, because we right this one was 102 and that's what we're on right now right yeah just cross it off and put that was the last one right you might have done yeah that was the just just cross it off so So this was 99.
Yeah, so just right.
Yeah.
And this is 99.
Correct.
Okay.
And they match.
Just cross it off.
So this was 99.
Yeah, so just cross it off the end.
And this is 99.
Correct.
Okay.
And they match.
So then the next one, we can use this and change it.
So this was 99.
Did they give you a blank?
No.
Not that I know of.
Yes, there is a 99.
There is a 99.
Okay.
So we can change that one.
Okay, so just change this.
Thank you.
Not that I know of.
Yes, there is an INAO.
There is an INAO.
So we can change that one.
Okay, so just change this.
So now you type in 102.
102, okay.
And then it goes out.
Okay.
AULT.
F-I-L-A-U-L-T.
Okay.
And then second mic.
And I can clean it up after.
Okay.
We don't have the other one.
Yes.
Thank you.
Okay, the clerk will now call the roll.
And I apologize.
Representative Ammon.
Yes.
Representative Osborne.
Representative Patusick.
Yes.
Representative Guthrie is not here.
Representative Post.
Yes.
Representative Cole.
Representative Presley.
Yes.
Representative Thaxton.
Representative Walsh.
Yes.
Representative Burroughs.
Representative Lane.
Yes.
She skipped you.
Representative Jack.
Yes.
Representative Calabro.
You skipped Herbert.
Yes.
Oh, I did.
I'm sorry.
Representative Herbert.
Yes.
And Vincent is not here and Calabro is yes.
Representative Filio?
Yes.
Representative Gibbs?
Representative Speer?
Yes.
Representative Sullivan?
Representative Hunt?
Yes.
Okay.
18 to zip for Senate Bill 102.
All those in favor of placing on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed, so move dynamically.
Okay.
Next up, Senate Bill 142 related to the regulation of forms and rates for property and casualty insurance.
I guess I'll do this one okay so up to pass and again this is another housekeeping bills for the insurance department but this one is property and and casualty rather than health insurance we have this the second oh second uh represent burrows okay any discussion on the motion of ought to pass on senate senate bill 142.
seeing none the clerk will call the roll representative amman yes representative osborne representative patusick yes Lane.
Yes.
Representative McAleer.
Excuse me, Representative Jack.
Representative Jack Potez, yes.
Thank you.
Representative Vincent isn't here.
Representative Calabro.
Yes.
Representative Filial.
Representative Gibbs.
Yes.
Representative Speer.
Representative Sullivan.
Yes.
Representative Hunt.
18 to 0.
Okay, motion passes 18 to zip.
All those in favor of placing Senate Bill 142 on the consent calendar please say aye aye those opposed so move dynamically okay Senate Bill 197 relative to the operation and regulation of certain business entities within the state.
Representative Cole.
Make a motion.
Ought to pass.
Okay.
Representative Cole, seconded by Representative Burroughs, moves ought to pass on Senate Bill 197.
And Representative Cole will speak to its motion.
Senate Bill 197 is creating a new designation for B corporations and allowing them to use the designation at the end of their title as PBC, Public Benefit Corps.
Well, one of the many little things that are in there, but this is a Secretary of State's housekeeping measure.
But, yes, the interesting one is that the B Corps now have a new identity.
So, any other discussion on the motion about to pass on Senate bill 197 see none the clerk will call the roll representative Ammon yes representative Osborne representative to sick representative Guthrie is not here representative post yes representative Cole yes representative Perselle representative faxton yes representative walsh representative burroughs yes representative herbert yes representative lane yes representative jack yes representative incidents not here representative collaboro yes representative Yesio yes representative gibbs yes representative spear yes representative sullivan and representative hunt yes okay vote 18 is zip all those in favor of placing Senate Bill 197 on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Those opposed, so moved unanimously.
Okay.
All right.
Next is Senate Bill 235, relative services provided through a primary care behavioral health model.
Okay.
We had the subcommittee this morning, and the subcommittee unanimously voted to retain this bill.
Anybody like to make that motion?
Okay.
Representative Patusek and seconded by Representative Gibbs moves to retain.
Any discussion on the motion?
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll.
Representative Ammon.
Yes.
Representative Osborne.
Representative Patusek.
Yes.
Representative Guthrie is not here.
Representative Post, yes.
Representative Cole.
Yes.
Representative Praselli.
Thank you.
Yes.
Representative Guthrie is not here.
Representative Post, yes.
Representative Cole.
Yes.
Representative Preselli.
Representative Thaxton.
Yes.
Representative Walsh.
Representative Burroughs.
Yes.
Representative Herbert.
Representative Lane.
Yes.
Representative Jack.
Representative Incident is not here.
Representative Calabro?
Yes.
Representative Filio?
Representative Gibbs?
Yes.
Representative Speer?
Sorry.
Yes.
Representative Sullivan?
And Representative Hunt?
Yes.
18 to zip.
Okay.
Vote 18 to zip.
All Senate Bill 243, all those in favor of placing 243 on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Oh, 235.
Never mind.
I keep running down on my checklist here.
I've got to put more space in the street.
Okay.
Now, Senate Bill 243, establishing a committee to study the implementation of a state-based health insurance exchange.
And Representative Speer, seconded by Representative Batusek, moves inexpedient to legislate.
And Representative Speer is recognized to speak to our motion.
This bill would establish a committee to study the implementation of a state-based exchange as opposed to the federal-based exchange that we currently have.
And we heard a lot of stuff in committee that explained why that may not be such a great idea.
So we voted to ITL it.
Fair enough.
Any other discussion on the motion to inexpedient legislate on 243?
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll.
Representative Ammon.
Yes.
Representative Osborne.
Thank you.
Expedient legislator on 243.
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll.
Representative Ammon.
Yes.
Representative Osborne.
Representative Patusick.
Yes.
Representative Guthrie is not here.
Representative Post.
Yes.
Representative Cole.
Representative Porcelli.
Yes.
Representative Thaxton.
Representative Walsh.
Yes.
Representative Burroughs.
Representative Herbert.
Yes.
Representative Lane.
representative faxton yes representative walsh representative burrows yes representative herbert yes representative lane yes representative jack yes representative vincent is not here representative collaboro yes representative filio yes representative gibbs yes representative spear yes representative sullivan representative hunt yes Representative Gibbs.
Yes.
Representative Spear.
Representative Sullivan.
Representative Hunt.
Yes.
Okay.
Motion passes 18 to zip.
All those in favor of placing Senate Bill 243 on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed?
So moved unanimously.
Senate Bill 198, directing the Insurance Department to conduct a cost study providing coverage for certain reproductive health care.
So the game plan is that we would retain this bill and that we would ask the Insurance Department to do a cost analysis on this piece of legislation.
Representative Filiad is still not happy.
Go ahead.
I do want to be on the record making an ought to pass motion on this because I believe it is important for LGBTQ couples to receive equity and their health care.
Okay.
Well, we're going to uh you can vote down vote against the retain motion.
But you obviously would argue that we should take a different motion.
I would argue that we should take a different motion against the retain motion since for the reasons that I've argued previously that LGBTQ couples should receive equity in their health care.
No, I realize that, but that's why you would urge people to vote against the retained motion.
That's exactly why I would urge people to vote against the retained motion.
I want to be on the record for that.
Perfect.
And you are.
You will be.
Okay, so the motion is to retain.
I have a question.
Yes, Representative Speer.
I went back and looked at the video actually i want to first i want to get a second on the motion i want to get first to accept so uh i make the retain motion and second by representative patousek okay yes now you can so i went back and looked at the video and there was a lawyer I don't remember her name, but she very clearly and concisely put together the whole crux of the problem and said very focused or pretty concisely what it is that the bill wanted to find.
And so my question is, if we did retain it, can we turn this thing into a law, into a legislation as opposed to a study committee?
Because if we just took her words, we would have the legislation that this thing is going for rather than spend however many months it takes to do a study committee.
So basically by our retaining, we will revisit this issue come September.
And at that point in time, it could be turned into anything you want to turn it into.
Yes, because we would then, just for your new members, remind you that we will come back in the fall and have our three divisions.
We'll take up the bills that were retained within them and discuss them.
And at that in time you the pending uh pending motions can be passing it amending it uh and uh but you would not be able to retain it again you could interim study it and the difference being where uh the interim study motion would come to the House floor and would be debated.
Theoretically.
Okay.
All right.
So the pending motion is to retain Senate Bill 243.
Representative Ammon.
Excuse me.
Did I do it again?
Senate Bill 198.
Yes.
Sorry.
Representative sorry representative Ammon yes representative Osborne representative Patusick representative Guthrie is not here representative Post yes representative Cole yes representative Percelli yes representative Thaxton Yes.
Representative Walsh.
Yes.
Representative Burroughs.
No.
Representative Herbert.
Representative Lane.
No.
Representative Jack.
Representative Vincent is not here.
Representative Calabro.
Yes.
Representative Filio.
No.
Representative Gibbs.
Yes.
Representative Filio?
No.
Representative Gibbs?
Yes.
Representative Spear?
Representative Sullivan?
Yes.
Representative Hunt?
That is 13 to 5.
13 to 5 to retain.
Okay.
Moving on.
Senate Bill 201 relative to resale of event tickets.
I thought we were going to retain this one, right?
Anybody want to make the motion to retain it?
Okay, Representative Ammon second.
I thought we were going to pass it.
No, no, no, we can't pass this bill.
Resale?
Resale has got all kinds of problems 201 correct yeah retain yeah that becomes well i thought it'd be let's get the motion to be sure we have the motion first we can have a discussion all right so representative am Representative Ammon second by Representative Patusek, move to retain.
But it was Representative Gibbs who pointed out that, you know, this happens every day when it comes to hotels.
I mean, if we're going to solve a problem for one, how are you going to solve it for everybody, right?
I mean, it's...
JetBlue does not.
Okay.
All right.
So the motion is to retain Senate Bill 201.
Is the question clear?
Okay.
Clerk will call the question clear?
Clerk will call the roll.
Representative Amman.
Yes.
Representative Osborne.
Representative Patousa.
Yes.
Representative Kathleen Van Heer.
Representative Post.
Yes.
Representative Cole.
Representative Prusselli.
Yes.
Representative Baxton.
Representative Walsh.
Yes.
Representative Burroughs.
Representative Herbert.
Yes.
Representative Speer.
Representative Sullivan.
Yes.
And Representative Hunt.
Okay.
The vote passes in 1927.
Okay, so going back to Senate Bill 198, I would like to entertain a motion, and I will say representative philo would make the motion seconded by uh representative burroughs that we will do a financial analysis on that bill.
You okay with that motion?
So move to do a financial analysis on Senate Bill 198.
There you go.
All right.
Any discussion on the motion to do this?
And basically, by doing this, we will send a memo to the Insurance Department, and they have already hired, they already have a consultant in mind who will be doing this financial analysis.
Okay.
All those in favor, please say aye.
Those opposed?
So move unanimously.
thank you uh may i just ask a question for clarification mr chairman yes um so that financial analysis might allow this to actually turn this into legislation and not need to establish a study committee that is true good thank you okay senate bill 60 Okay.
Senate Bill 60.
I missed something on that one.
Do we do another line for this?
No, you don't have to worry.
Well, we just did.
You don't need to worry about it.
Okay.
Next is Senate Bill 66.
I got it right?
Relative to financial transactions involving the liquidation or rehabilitation of an insurer in which the Federal Home Loan Bank is a party.
Anybody want to make the motions on this one?
Who are the sponsors?
Okay.
I will make the motion since I was a sponsor.
And Representative Patusek, second.
O Patusek, yes, ought to pass.
Well, this was a really inside baseball one.
And I remember I had a...
Yes, we had the bank.
You want to explain it?
Any turns?
I guess not.
Okay.
Yeah, so this is clarification.
You know, is this more of an insurance?
And they just left the room, right?
Okay.
What's that?
It's 402C.
It's definitely an insurance.
Okay.
This was a request by the insurance department.
So there'll be no problems with it.
No problems with this, right?
Okay.
That's right.
It was a of over because there are other right okay it's a parody in dealing with uh depository uh institutions some already have this protections and others don't not so any discussion on the motion of ought to pass all right seeing none the clerk will call the roll representative ammon yes representative osborne representative patusick yes representative guthrie is not here representative post yes Yes.
Representative Cole.
Yes.
Representative Presley.
Representative Thaxton.
Yes.
Representative.
jack yes representative vincent is not here representative collaboro yes representative filio yes representative gibbs yes representative spear yes representative sullivan representative hunt yes 18 to 0.
okay motion passes uh to zip.
All those in favor of placing it on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed, so move unanimously.
Okay, last one on the list here.
uh senate bill 37 establishing committee to study the hospitality and tourism education in New Hampshire representative spear represent spears second by representative to sake moves in expedient to legislate and representative spears recognizes speak to her motion.
This bill would have established a commission to study hospitality and tourism education in New Hampshire.
We've had several bills in the past this session come through various committees on the House that have turned these kinds of things down.
It's a study that, as we heard from the witnesses at the hearing, they have already been working these issues.
The various hotels have worked things with people living in the areas.
They've talked to colleges already.
It doesn't need legislation to get involved in the middle of that.
They already seem to have a good handle on what they're doing, on what they need.
And it should be a discussion between the hospitality groups and the universities without us in the middle of it.
Fair enough.
Any other discussion on the motion of inexperience to legislate?
Seeing none, the clerk will roll representative Ammon yes representative Osborne representative Petusik yes representative Guthrie is not here representative Post yes representative Cole yes representative Percelli yes representative Thaxton yes representative Walshalsh.
Yes.
Representative Burroughs.
Representative Herbert.
Yes.
Representative Lane.
Representative Jack.
Yes.
Representative Incident's not here.
Representative Calabro.
Yes.
Representative Filio.
Representative Gibbs.
Yes.
Representative Spear.
Representative Sullivan.
Yes.
Representative Hunt.
18-20.
representative gibbs yes representative spear yes representative sullivan representative hunt yes vote 18 to zip all those in favor placing on the consent calendar please say aye those opposed so moved unanimously do we need a minority?
No, no, no.
No, minority.
Oh, no.
Okay.
I had 20 seats.
We could work it out.
Okay.
So, six.
You coming to lunch.
7, 8, 9, 10.
You have to interject.
Do you want to come?
Okay.
11, 12, 13, 14.
So we're all good.
Good.
We had one.
So that we need to report on it.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'd like to open up the executive session at Senate Bill 180.
So I would like to make a motion to retain Senate Bill 180.
Second.
Why?
Representative Gibbs seconded.
Okay.
So, before, we don't even have to talk about the amendments, because obviously the underlying bill needs to be amended anyways with a .3.
But at this point, the problem I'm kind of, that I was dealing with in my mind was when we passed this in the subcommittee, that we said we were going to be okay with the bill, we were conscious of the fact that in Senate Bill, excuse me, House Bill 639, we had a study committee to study the issue of this Delta 8 and Delta 9.
And I sense from everybody that there's a little stress on whether 659 is actually going to live another day.
And therefore, if it really wasn't going to pass, if it's not going to pass, then we really shouldn't be passing this because the study committee won't occur.
So we could, you know, so I said, well, we need to study this.
So we could put this off and we can amend it to have a study committee to address this Delta 8, Delta 9, and whatever, how much THC is actually really in it.
I mean, 0.3 seems like a pretty small number to me.
And it's compared to the 0.05 that we have in non-alcoholic beer.
And so therefore it really isn't marijuana because of the 0.3.
And so I'm just thinking that at the end of the day we really don't need to pass this bill.
And the right answer is for us at this point to just retain it and live another day.
So Representative Spears first.
The only comment I have is we can't pass it the way it is because it's still wrong.
Perfect.
It says 0.3 percent greater than 0.3 percent and needs to say less than 0.3% otherwise it makes no sense this is the amendment the amendment is i i i guess i would i would have to say i disagree the idea is that um see if it's oh i see you're right yeah because i forgot this you're right it it should be less than you're right okay yes as per your email which representative selen though it seems to me that we were in agreement that this should pass because the idea of like there being zero regulation on something and and these these uh cbd oils can be turned into thc products delta nines or i don't know much about this stuff but it sounded to me like even if we can't get 639 which had a study committee this might have maybe made a study committee unnecessary maybe I mean in reality it sounds like this might be the solution the reality is anybody can go buy something there's no ID checks there's no regulation of of how it's produced how it's tested what it actually is that to me seems like an issue that we should address uh retaining it I don't know what the point is aside from maybe we're just I don't know I don't know what the goal is if it's like leverage to try to get 639 but i don't know if that would work because the senate seems to be kind of stubborn on this but it doesn't mean that this is a bad bill i think that this seems like a good bill from my understanding and i i think we should pass it because i think it's we're here to try to make things a little it better and i don't think a free-for-all on this, on vaping various types of THC, Delta 9, and these Delta letters after them is something that most people even understand is actually happening.
I was surprised to learn that.
So you would be okay if it was someone who was over 21?
What's that?
An age requirement.
Yeah, I mean, that's fine.
Whatever.
Right.
So I'm saying the problem with this bill was it was banning it altogether.
So if we retain it, we could, come September, pass it with just 21.
Okay.
That makes sense.
As long as it's not a retain to die no thank you yes I agree that this is a good bill that needs a few corrections.
The reason that I seconded the motion to retain is that I think with making a few corrections, this bill should be passed.
I think trying to combine it with 639, much as I would have liked to see 639 signed into law um it seems like there's a good chance that trying to combine 180 and 639 will end up killing both of them and that it would be better to retain 180 and make a couple of corrections um and pass it in the next session than to try and go back and combine it with 639.
That was why I seconded the motion to retain fair enough representative burrows no at my point okay representative amin so i also support retain um the bill obviously came to us with not fully baked.
And we also heard this is a national issue caused by national legislation.
And some of the examples that we heard were from other states, like I think Florida is one that I remember from the testimony.
So I think taking our time with this is the right approach so i support retain thank you anybody else okay seeing that uh so i make the motion to retain do i and representative gives seconds the clerk will call the roll for retaining representative.
Yes.
Representative Osborne.
Representative Patusick.
Yes.
Representative Terry.
Representative Post says yes.
Representative Cole.
Yes.
Representative Percelli.
Representative Thaxton.
Yes., representative Walsh.
Yes.
Oh, representative Burroughs.
Representative Herbert.
Yes.
Representative Lane.
Representative Jack.
Yes.
Representative Vincent is not here representative colabro not here um representative filio yes representative um sorry representative gibbs yes Yes.
Representative Sullivan?
Yes.
Representative Hunt?
18.
How can it be 18?
We have one, two, two people missing.
16.
17.
okay motion passes 18 to 0.
it can't be it can't be 18.
so i have one two three four five who didn't who isn't here right because we we picked up Terry and we lost our pairing.
Oh, so it is 18.
Okay.
Because I'm like, I'm looking at the numbers and they say okay.
Okay, motion passes, 18 to zip.
All those, oh, this way.
We don't put it on the cantalor.
We're all set.
Okay.
As a first-time candidate, I would like to say thank you for the nice time.
Nice time.
Okay.
well uh i will officially end the exact session and i would say that uh every year i do this and people say why do you keep doing it?
And I said, because it never ceases to have fun.
I just, what we do is amazing, and we accomplish a lot, and we're doing a lot of good stuff for New Hampshire, and I am so proud of this committee.
What are you last term?
I'm always proud.
Might have to go farther back for them, maybe.
Not so proud, but, you know, even, and you asked me before, even when I've been in the minority, I've always been, feel like I walked away feeling like, you know, that i was hurt i i got what i needed to get across and and uh um i i think this committee is the best committee all right I'll see you all 18.
Oh, next no session tomorrow, but I will see you all soon.
But the committee committee will not necessarily we will not be back until September.
Generally, we'll do it sometime in September.
Oh.
Thank you.